they quarantined the systems
shut down the network to stop whatever
was capping the locals
so behind each of these gates is a solar
system full of whatever made the proto
molecule
miller laughed something in the sound of
it sent a shiver down holding spine
that seems pretty unlikely why this
station has been waiting for the all
clear signal to open the network back
up for about two billion years if they'd
found a solve they wouldn't still be
waiting whatever it was
i think it got them all all of them but
you holden said
not kid i'm one of them like the ross
ante is one of you
the rossi's smart for a machine it knows
a lot about you
it could probably gin up a rough
simulation of you if someone told it to
those things the ones you felt like
compared to them
i'm a fancy kind of hand terminal and
then nothing it explains holden said you
mean what killed them
well if we're gonna be fair it's not
really nothing miller said crossing his
arms we know it ate a galaxy spanning
hive consciousness like it was popcorn
so that's something
and we know it survived a sterilization
that was a couple hundred solar systems
wide
hey guys pete here it's time for part
three of my expanse proto molecule
series today i'm going to be discussing
the
investigator that fancy kind of hand
terminal that also happens to appear to
holden as everyone's favorite belter
detective
josephus miller we'll also discuss the
mysterious artifact that he discovered
on
illus which he dubbed the bullet doing
that will involve some spoilers
if you've not watched the expanse tv
series through episode 1 of season 5
then there will be some things here you
might be seeing for the first time
i've read the books the show's based on
and i'll be referring
to those a lot but only up to and
including nemesis games with that out of
the way let's get started
in part one of this series we talked
about what the proto-molecule
is not in itself a living thing but a
set of free-floating instructions
designed to adapt and guide other
replicating systems
how the bit of proto-molecule that got
sent to soul system got trapped in
saturn's gravity
and how that stopped it from completing
its mission for over 2 billion years
we talked about how humanity discovered
it how they tried to use it for their
own means
and how that made it possible for it to
move forward with what it was sent to do
in the first place
build the ring gate in part two we
talked about what the ring gate actually
is plus the network of other gates it's
attached to
and how the alien civilization that
created it all
no longer exists most of what we learned
about them
came from interactions james holden had
with what looked like our old friend
detective miller we'll come back to that
in just a minute but what i hope you
took away from the first two videos
is this the protomolecule is a tool the
long extinct gate builder civilization
used that tool to create a network of
wormhole gates
through each of these gates lies a
system with at least one habitable
planet and they all connect around a hub
in the non-space that's referred to as
the slow zone
this isn't the only way the tool can be
used and it isn't the only tool they
have in their toolbox but it is what the
load that phoebe was carrying was for
because it took so long for this ring
gate to open and connect to the network
there was nobody there when it happened
that meant it couldn't complete the next
step in its process
that's all it was designed to do and
that brings us to the subject of today's
video
what does the proto-molecule do when it
can't report to the station that work on
the ring gate is complete
it creates the investigator the creation
is a tool for a specific
purpose to figure out why it can't
complete its task
that's pretty straightforward but
because the civilization that created it
was so advanced the things it can do
aren't always easy to grasp in our story
no one understands this better than
james holden who has his brain
manipulated in a way that makes him see
hallucinations of miller because active
protomolecule was left behind on the
rossi
after the hybrid incident it became a
node on the network
and a possible path to utilize to
complete the task
because detective miller's consciousness
was absorbed into the hive mine on the
way to venus
it's able to use that to contact holden
he first experiences this around the
time that the slingshotter moneo flew
his ship the yk
into the ring in the beginning the
things he says don't make any sense and
lead holden to think he's going insane
since he can check for that sort of
thing with their auto dock
he figures out that he's not and then
starts to believe he's being manipulated
by the protomolecule
in a way he's not wrong but given the
circumstances he unsurprisingly
misinterprets why that's happening
holden has his first real conversation
with the investigator when he travels
alone to
the ring station they're able to
communicate in a coherent way
the investigator makes it so that he can
go inside the structure
because he needs his help to access what
he calls the records
i discussed most of what happens here in
my previous video and this is when we
learn a lot of the details about how it
is that holden has been seeing him in
the first place
the important thing that happens here
for the investigator is he learns that
the gate builder civilization is gone
he learns how that happened and holden
sees that too
the important thing that happens for
humanity is that miller explains that if
the ships in the slow zone power down
their reactors
the station will no longer see them as a
threat and then he can shut down the
security system
when he does that it will also reopen
the network giving them
access to all of the rings and therefore
all 1300 systems that lie beyond them he
takes hold into one of the planets one
that
is very similar to earth in a vision
slash hallucination
and there he explains what he's actually
made to do that goes like this
i wasn't built to fix [ __ ] humanity
broke miller said i didn't come here to
open gates for you
and get the lockdown to let you go
that's incidental the thing that made me
just builds roads and now it's using me
to find out what happened to the galaxy
spanning civilization
that wanted the road why does that
matter if they're all gone
it doesn't miller said with a weary
shrug not a bit
if you set the nav computer on the rossi
to take you somewhere and then fall over
dead a second later can the rossi decide
it doesn't matter anymore and just not
go
no holden said understanding and finding
a sadness for this miller construct he
wouldn't have guessed was possible
we were supposed to connect with the
network we're just trying to do that
doesn't matter that the network's gone
what came up off of venus's dumb kid
just knows how to do one thing it
doesn't know how to investigate but i do
and it had me so i'm going to
investigate even though none of the
answers will mean [ __ ] all to the
universe at large
that's their last interaction in the
third book and the third season of the
show
and at the end of that he hints that
he'll still need holden's help to
continue
he tells him that he'll need a ride so
to recap
the real detective miller died on the
way to venus with his consciousness
being absorbed
into the ring building project when the
ring gate was finished it tried to
complete the next step which was to
connect to the network at the ring
station
not able to do that it eventually
created the investigator
as a tool to figure out what was wrong
in that process it used the
protomolecule on the rossi
to reach out and manipulate holden's
brain making him
see and interact with a construct based
on miller
this displays aspects of miller's
personality those are artifacts that are
built
into it and it does help humanity get
out of the situation in the slow zone
but it only exists for the purpose of
investigating initially why it wasn't
able to connect to the ring station
network and then later what happened to
the civilization that built it
as far as why it contacted holden in the
first place
he asked this question to the
investigator directly inside
the station before he touches the big
thing in the middle of the room i get
why no one else sees you but the real
question is why me at all
i mean okay you're screwing with my
brain and that's hard work and if
there's other people for me to interact
with it's too hard and all like that
but why me why not naomi or the un
secretary general or something
miller nodded understanding the question
he frowned
sighed miller kinda liked you thought
you were a decent guy
that's it you need more book four cibola
byrne is where we learn a lot more about
how the investigator functions
because it includes several interludes
which are basically chapters from
its point of view they read like a
stream of consciousness
and the first one starts like this it
reaches out
it reaches out it reaches out it reaches
out
113 times a second nothing answers and
it reaches out
it is not conscious though parts of it
are there are structures within it that
were once separate organisms
aboriginal evolved and complex it is
designed to improvise to use what is
there and then move on
good enough is good enough and so the
artifacts are ignored or adapted
the conscious parts try to make sense of
the reaching out
try to interpret it we learn some new
things from these interludes and get
some clarification about what's
happening
early on when the investigator would
reappear it didn't have a memory of
talking to holden before
this is because it was essentially
killed and recreated over and over again
it uses miller's consciousness creates
the investigator
and lets it investigate on its own with
some limiting boundary conditions
the rossi and the crew go to ellis which
has
a lot of proto-molecule-built artifacts
on the planet itself and this opens a
new pathway for the investigator to look
for clues as to what happened to the
gate builder civilization
because there's active proto-molecule on
the rossi things get turned on
the investigator is able to access the
network there
to look around and eventually it
discovers a place where the
proto-molecule can't go
this is a clue and so it focuses on
trying to understand what it is
the interlude says this and instead
there's a dead place
a place where nothing is where nothing
pulls back the investigator reaches out
and what reaches out dies the
investigator ceases to reach out
it waits it considers something was here
once something built
all this and left its meal half eaten on
the table
the designers and engineers that spanned
a thousand worlds had lived here and
died here and left behind the everyday
wonders like bones in the desert the
investigator knows this
the world is a crime scene and the one
thing that stands out the one thing that
doesn't belong
is the place that nothing goes it's an
artifact
in a world of artifacts but it doesn't
fit what would they put in a place they
couldn't reach
is it a prison a treasure chest a
question that isn't supposed to be
asked a bullet a bomb still ticking
under the kitchen table after the blitz
was over
the investigator talks holden into going
to where the bullet is
mercury interrupts as he doesn't want
the protomolecule tech shut down
even though everyone is probably going
to die and so holden has to stop and
deal with that
he asked elvia koye to help the
investigator
who has now figured out how to put
himself into something physical
it's a proto-molecule tech robot
basically after being created and
destroyed
over and over knowing that there's no
way to connect back to the gate builders
because they're gone
the investigator begins to see the
bullet as his way out this is partially
due to the influence of miller's
consciousness
and the show illustrated this by having
him start to appear without the hat
towards the end of season four the thing
that created it only knows how to
survive
and to reach out and to try to make the
final connection
it can create the investigator it can
kill the investigator
and in that process the investigator
learns how to die
that is the plan with elvis help the
investigator plans to pass through the
bullet after it connects to
everything on illus it needs lv because
after it connects
the protomolecule will try to stop it
she's able to get him there
and the bullet kills him and everything
he's connected to
in the final interlude it plays out like
this the investigator pushes his hat
back
wishes he had a beer he likes this woman
this lb he
wishes he had a little more time to know
her he wishes he had a little more time
he doesn't care he has died a million
times since he died
the void has no mysteries for him now he
connects
and the investigator becomes the world
he feels it everywhere
the orbital bases the power cores in the
crushing depth of the ocean
the library vaults where the old ones
had lived the signaling stations high in
the mountains
the cities deep beneath the ground he is
the world there is a struggle at the end
there's always a struggle at the end
he's not scared and so
all through the world the others aren't
either you're like peter pan she says
when a child died peter pan would fall
halfway with them so they wouldn't be
scared
weird and that's a kid's story anyway
it's not me the investigator says
smiles at her holds her hand i don't go
for half
it reaches out and it reaches out and it
reaches out
and then it stops so that is the end for
this version of miller and the activated
protomolecule tech on illus
it's not exactly clear what that means
in the big picture of what the gate
builders left behind
the investigator did connect to the
network at the ringgate station when he
was there which means his consciousness
probably still exists
there's still more active protomolecule
out there and now more than 300 new
worlds that can be filled with artifacts
just like illus
for the bullet it seems to be a weapon
that was specifically designed to kill
the gate builders
elvi had an interesting experience when
she passed through it but it didn't kill
her
in the beginning of season five we
learned that she stayed on illus to
study it
and that she created a simulation of
what she saw when she passed through it
but she doesn't have a clear explanation
of what it is
or what's going on with it when holden
and fred johnson look at the sim he
explains that it's a visualization of
what killed the builders
wiping out their civilization in an
instant since no more of these have
appeared on any of the other colony
worlds they visited
fred's skeptical about whether this is
something they need to be concerned with
holden tells him that every time he
passes through a ring he thinks he sees
their world
the unknown aggressor's world and every
time he sees them
he thinks they look angrier he worries
that humans are waking them up and
that's probably not something that
humans want to do
in the end the gate builders were far
more advanced than humans
and whatever created this bullet was
powerful enough to erase them from
existence
they were galaxy spanning they were able
to harness wormhole technology for
faster than light travel
and built this elaborate network that
connected all of these habitable systems
together
we know that humans will use the ring
gates that they built to colonize the
new worlds that's already happening and
so we have to wonder
how the builders put themselves on the
unknown aggressor's radar in the first
place
and that seems like a good place to
bring this video to an end
ripped to the investigator ripped to the
original detective miller he was a great
character and who knows
he may come back at some point in the
future although i think his story is
complete
in his service to the proto molecule
which is just trying to complete its
task
we learned a lot about the gate builders
and that there is a threat that's bigger
than them
that could play an important role in the
story in the future
and i will leave it there please let me
know in the comments what you think
about the investigator
if you have any questions about it if
you have any questions about the proto
molecule in general
if you're going to discuss things that
happen in books past nemesis games
please mark those as book spoilers so
people who are just watching the show
won't get spoiled for future events
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon